what did you think of nate and leon i
loved it i loved that nate and
kind of rallied in the end nate last 30
seconds durable
he's just so durable and uh he's just a
little disappointed in leon
i thought leon was gonna because he's
that new blood i mean he pitched a
shutout stuff for the last 30 seconds
but
he didn't it's not like he didn't show
up he just couldn't get rid of him yeah
part of it was also
maybe you know it's it's all experience
fighting a veteran that's a lot of
energy leon's super experience
he's experienced but you know that's
sometimes that can [ __ ] with you a
little bit when you got the whole
crowd going nate and they can you know
but i thought he did a great job
well you said his last loss was to us
guzman yeah
here five six years ago oh [ __ ] yeah
he's he's a high-level [ __ ] man
but nate nate's just
you know so much fun so game but yeah
i i feel bad for leon because the
narrative is just it's all about nate
now
yeah not leon yeah i think he knew that
right i think he knew that nate
i mean leon leon no he didn't want that
to happen but nate's going in as an
underdog so
you're going to know that the crowd is
going to be for oh no he knew that but i
think
he thought he'd beat him and then you
know the narrator would be about him but
right even though he oh big time the
plus 500 yeah
which right i mean you saw how the fight
was yeah they only landed one right hand
the entire fight
yeah another high level kickboxer like
high level guy you know an athletic and
you know the whole deal he's so
entertaining to watch nate
i feel like just because he the beating
he can take on like he's he's a showman
i feel like he's
old school yeah that's how i look at it
i look at boxing in jiu jitsu
old school he fights like he's on the
streets of uh stockton it's kind of
historical the way he just walks around
kind of like he kept turning his back to
[ __ ] with leon i i loved it it made me
yeah it's only cute if you're winning
yeah i agree but i mean like
he loses so he's he's lost seven out of
eight rounds his last fight
he got absolutely destroyed by mazda i
had two of those rounds 10 8.
yeah and so he's lost every single round
except for that last right hand
i yeah he's definitely past his prime
fighting-wise i feel like i'll always
pay to watch him fight
but to me the the antics like you got
you gotta you gotta be winning
yeah i i agree with you but it's in the
moment it's fun too like it's one yeah
we don't see it no one really does it
yeah
i i does brother do the same [ __ ] too i
love nick oh he's bro
yeah i love nick monster it was my
favorite fighter are you a fan
are you a fan chin of them other than
the diaz brothers of course yeah
i don't know anyone who doesn't really
yeah how do you not like i don't know
why i'm a fan i'm just like every time i
watch like
if they're on tv yeah they're they're
just interesting to watch like
yeah they're interesting to watch yeah
they're fun to watch exactly
and just great they seem real too like
super travel man yeah
yeah yeah no i'm a fan they beat the
game you know yeah they did they beat
they've i just worry about the amount of
just the head trauma that they do but
that's yeah you should
yeah yeah because they they they did a
lot of boxing
out of in in
and i you know that those guys that's
not you're not just moving around you're
getting
[ __ ] cracked one of the best ever
andre
nate's also been in the ufc for what 10
years now i think more than that more
like well he would the ufc i think is
he's been mixed martial arts for
17 years yeah but i thought that he was
in wc and ufc
yeah then one ultimate fighter i think
that you his ufc i could be wrong the
ufc debut i
think was around 2007 or maybe that was
his first loss or something uh
because i was looking at his stats over
the weekend he fought
the ultimate fighter finale 2007. wow
wc was in 2007. yeah think about 2004
they started fighting
well his first fight was in the wc he's
been fighting since 2004 jesus
and how old is he and he's only been
he's only been finished once
i teach 38 30 36 36
he's the he those brothers are so
durable it's crazy
and he's i mean nick's never been nick
got hit by
paul daley is that is it paul daley well
daley gave him a left hook and he went
down on his phone
on his hands and knees and came back and
knocked paul daley out with a left hook
it's like when you're fighting a guy
like paul daley you're supposed to do
the other stuff you're not supposed to
try to match their he's like nah i'm
gonna i'm gonna match you punch for
punch
they're crazy man they're just like such
outliers they're outlines they're just
outliers of
crazy cardiovascular outliers they do a
lot of um
triathlons and i think nick oh they do i
think nate was talking about how they
used to train because they didn't have
any money
and they'd get a burrito after training
there was like you know it's just real
hunger man
how they have each other's back which
one's the older one
one on the left oh okay that's nick diaz
that was my favorite nick's election
hall of famer [ __ ] was he is he
retired no he's supposed to fight this
year oh god who is he gonna fight he's
been off for a long time
we have no clue who's gonna fight but
dana said they're gonna fight we have no
clue who
there's also i think that's just because
nick diaz give him a title shot
yeah yeah how i'm fighting that you want
to pave to watch nick
is he kidding me oh yeah how great with
the antics being the build up and [ __ ]
what else we gonna do whitaker again it
just means funny too
no notice like nobody complains nate
fought leon yeah
no business fight lane he's coming off a
loss fighting number three guy in the
world on
nine fight win streak nope nobody
complained we're all like hell yeah
that's cool
anybody else you'd be [ __ ] furious
the ds brother's right yeah and the
fighters would probably be like cool
usually fires be like that that should
be my smart whatever
[Music]
that'd be so funny